platforms that have the attention are  changing right now and every time they  change crazy [ __ ] happens so Facebook  fan page number one YouTube shorts  number two Tick Tock number three you  must dominate those three arbitrages how  many pieces  ideal for per platform on those and then  there's Twitter and Instagram and  regular YouTube and Link and Linkedin  and content creation is more about  post-production than actually your time  I couldn't give a bigger  Facebook fan pages YouTube Shorts  YouTube shorts is Tick Tock except it's  YouTube which means it's searchable the  fact that I would spend my time on  Facebook fan page First Youtube short  second Tick Tock third is a profound  shift in a room full of people that have  Instagram first